bonsoir 21 ans merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur la tvh france le passé ni
terre obligatoire dès aujourd'hui donc
on l'a dit dans dans la restauration
qu'est-ce qui est mis concrètement en
place pour les salariés
pour les salariés ou pour les
entreprises pour qu'on laisse l aller
oui mais pas pour les autres pour les
deux nés de et bien écoutez le fonds de
solidarité évidemment il était prévu
qu'ils le s'amoindrit fur et à mesure du
temps et donc comme à dix ministres
effectivement on est passé de 10 fois
moins de demande donc ça c'est bon signe
pour la restauration et l'hôtellerie
enfin surtout la restauration et les
cafés l'hôtellerie c'est plus compliqué
mais donc ce fonctionnalité va être
adaptée à chaque situation et on va il
vendu cher il a donc se faire du cas par
cas et a fini les aides en fonction de
la réalité des besoins des
professionnels qui sera encore
difficulté quand vous échanger avec vos
salariés aujourd'hui dans quel état
d'esprit sont ils par ce qu'il y à
beaucoup quand même de de pression aussi
à on le voit lorsque l'on va dans un
restaurant depuis quelques jours ils
n'ont pas l'impression de se transformer
en rencontres olharan rang gendarmes
oui alors évidemment il ya eu beaucoup
d'inquiétudes c'est normal puisque on
découvrait une nouvelle fonction qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas dans nos gènes
puisqu'on est là pour l'accueil pour le
plaisir pour le sourire et non pour des
contrôles sanitaires donc il a fallu
s'adapter et mettre en place le pass
sanitaire des big man globalement ça
s'est très bien passé il ya quelques cas
très très lent petit nombre qui a qui
ont refusé certaines choses mais
globalement ça s'est globalement bien
passée les français l'ont accepté les
les entreprises ont mis avant
d'appliquer tout simplement la loi parce
qu on est dans l'obligation d'appliquer
la loi maintenant aujourd'hui on a en
plus le contrôle des salariés et plus de
80% des salariés étaient avaient leur
passe ses nerfs avait là une vaccination
ou un test pcr donc que dire bon an mal
an on va dire que les choses se passent
pas si mal que ça et et avec un état qui
va continuer à surveiller et à aider le
plus possible ceux qui sont en grande
difficulté en prenant
choses dans l'ordre tout d'abord puisque
cette confusion de départ les salariés
quand il refuse justement se passa ni
terre quelle est l'attitude que doit
adopter l'entreprise est ce que vous
êtes accompagné sur ce point parce qu'on
veut bien appliquer la loi mais enfin il
faut tout de même être
accompagné puisque une fois encore ce
n'est pas votre coeur de métier le
contrôle non bien sûr que c'est
difficile ça crée des relations ça va
créer des relations très compliquées
pour des personnes qui sont anti vaccins
majoritairement c'est surtout là qu'il
peut y avoir des tensions il y à il ya
des solutions intermédiaires avant de
passer vraiment à la solution radicale
qui est de se séparer d'un salarié ce
qui est quand même un peu difficile ça
peut éventuellement aller jusque là mais
je pense qu'on arrivera pas jusque là je
pense que tout le monde sait qu'il faut
pour garder son emploi et pour pour que
ça se passe bien faire en sorte d'avoir
un d'avoir une vaccination complète et
sont passés à lithaire donc il ya des
mesures intermédiaire avant qu'ils sont
de prendre des congés qui sont prendre
dé prendre des derrière péter c'est sûr
que c'est pas facile à appliquer dans un
secteur où il manque de salariés où il
manque de personnel surtout en salle ça
va être celle à la faisabilité de de
suspendre quelqu'un soit de le mettre en
vacances là de mettre dans un autre
poste parce que les postes dans la
restauration sont pas interchangeables
soit vous êtes en salsa vous êtes en
cuisine on peut pas mettre un serveur en
cuisine sous prétexte que il n'a pas
s'en passe donc ça ça bouscule
complètement le fonctionnement du durée
ce temps messi à plus de 80% les
personnels à son passé ni terre je pense
que les choses vont se régler j'espère
et est ce que j'entends et ce que je
vois de mes collègues et nous mêmes il
ya des choses se passent assez assez
assez sympathique mais en gagne un
est-ce que ça se passe aussi
sympathiquement on a commencé à en
parler tout à l'heure à l'entrée des
restaurants vous nous disiez oui dans la
majorité des cas mais est ce que ces
personnels sont formés devant des refus
on a vu qu'il ya beaucoup de colère dans
le pays beaucoup d'incompréhension il ya
des manifestations anti pas cela ni
terre tous les week-ends 200 villes de
france encore ce week-end quelle est
l'attitude ados tu es là encore est ce
que ces salariés sont sont accompagnés
pour avoir la marche à suivre
bien sûr nous sommes pas désunis nos
serveurs ne sont pas des agents de
sécurité nous sommes nous mêmes par des
agents de sécurité dans un monde idéal
il aurait été formidable d'avoir une
personne dédiée à cette fonction qui
aurait pour le client une respectabilité
plus plus imposante que de quelqu'un du
personnel de la salle où même le chef
d'entreprise mais bon comme on n'a pas
les moyens ni ni la possibilité de dans
le retour à des petites structures les
grandes structures de restauration ont
pu
utiliser des agents de sécurité qui est
pour eux beaucoup plus facile d'imposer
le pass mais on a on a vu que je veux
dire les français en allant restaurant
il savait avec toute la communication
l'information vous avez tous donné que
pour aller au restaurant il fallait un
pass sanitaire donc on a affaire à
quelques rétro et quelques personnes qui
sont au vaccin d'ailleurs les
manifestations certes elles ont lieu
mais comparé au nombre de personnes
vaccinées et nombre de personnes dans
les rues c'est sûr que peut-être que
c'est un peu disproportionnée la la
teneur dans laquelle on les met
aujourd'hui donc nous pour l'instant on
a on a eu un ou deux cas en france dans
la restauration où il ya eu des
contrôles un peu un peu un peu moins
moins sympathique serait dû se passer
mais je veux dire deux trois cas dans la
france entière c'est quand même pas
énorme donc on va pour une fois je vais
assez optimiste allez un peu de l'avant
et en se disant que en espérant que le
15 novembre
remettent le fonctionnement d'un
restaurant dans un état normal et
conviennent au restaurant non pas pour
se faire contrôler mais pour passer un
bon moment je pense que c'est ce qu'il
faut espérer que le taux de vaccination
validation justement la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte
un protocole sanitaire quand même
contraignant vous avez joué le jeu pour
beaucoup de restaurants dont vont se
passer les nerfs
mais tout de même ce variant delta qui
continue à nous embêter d'avis et j'ose
dire vous êtes optimiste vous sûr sûr
sûr l'avenir clairement bas je ne suis
pas médecin je suis cuisinier jeu
j'essaie de
c'est un métier c'est un métier où il
faut s'adapter tous les matins quand on
ouvre notre restaurant donc il a pu
s'adapter on est habitué à s'adapter pas
modifié mais s'adapter donc on espère qu
effectivement par rapport à tout ce que
l'on nous explique on devrait arriver à
ce que
le 15 novembre ont soit débarrassé
venteux vendu pas sanitaires pourraient
dans les restaurants en sachant quand
même que un restaurant n'est pas un lieu
de contamination
ça n'a jamais été démontrée puisque le
malheureusement le virus s'est
développée lorsqu'on était fermée donc
ans tout le monde sait que c'est dans
les regroupements familiaux dans les
réunions privées où les gens et aucune
consigne de sécurité pas de port du
masque de se laver les mains vingt
personnes pour les contraindre à avoir
un minimum de sécurité sanitaire ou les
houles et le virus a circulé donc nos
établissements depuis la 1er
déconfinement et la première ouverture
ont mis des protocoles sanitaires
drastiques et appliquée dans les
restaurants on est des gens
professionnels responsables on a tout
intérêt à ce que ça se passe bien afin
que les français les clients en général
sache que d'aller dans un restaurant
c'est pas un endroit dangereux bien au
contraire mais si jean terlon d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france